I said hey now I saw your messages you  sent me oh man I saw it I saw it on the  seventh and I left you on red and then  you went out there and you you started  talking to the peoples now I thought  they was about not snitching  that's that's you you ratted me out man  I said you know what I need to come out  and talk  it's absolutely inadequate why is 10  years inadequate for you because they  know after that 10 years I'm dead  [ __ ] up on me  it's absolutely  I'm gonna go for no tenure I want it for  life I'm here for you you wanted it  perfectly but let me tell you something  I don't even want it  what I just want to do is block them  I just want to stop them it just  wouldn't stop I'm bucking up all over  them